after five days of thrilling chess
action we are finally ready to crown a
champion i am joined here in the studio
by michael kadarkovsky the executive
director of the grand chess tour adam
ceo of superbad poland and jan shishtav
duda michael i'm going to give you the
first word
uh thank you christian uh indeed
there were five exciting days with three
days of rapid than tiger of madras
former world champion
vichyanan took first place but then two
exciting
days when uh young
duda
was able to overcome
uh deficits and points and in the last
round and grab
the win
for
first
ever grandchild's tour
here in warsaw poland and i would like
to congratulate of course
uh the winner on one hand on another end
i want to thank super bad foundation and
super bad poland for hosting this event
and sponsoring this event
and
we look forward to see
uh and third
lag
in zagreb
even more exciting games that we have
seen here in warsaw
and i would like to pass
the microphone to
super bet poland's ceo
adam lamented
thank you michael it's great to be here
a lot of emotions at the end so
still excited and
thank you very much
uniting minds
it was a great experience for us here in
poland
lots of people lots of spectators and
first of all
top chess players of the world
and i as polish national i couldn't hope
for better ending
so i really congratulate janek for for
this result it's a great pleasure
to be here with you and uh to be the
host of this event and thank you very
much to granchester for the trust to
host it for the first time in poland
please present the trophy to the winner
very beautifully
yan shishtav a crazy day please describe
to us our feelings right now
yeah i'm extremely happy of course to
win this event
um
i can say that i'm kind of i mean i'm
recognized as a kind of specialist but
i must confess that
it was extremely difficult i feel
extremely difficult um
opponents
and um
yeah i'm very happy actually to win it
because it was of course very nervous
till the very end
and um
yeah it's very
very very special
i mean it is very nice that uh i have
one here in warsaw in poland
um
it has a special value to me
tell us what does it mean to win in
front of your home crowd
yeah it feels very nice and
i guess i'm about to see
what it's uh what is coming actually
you are one and a half points behind the
leader going into today's rounds what
was the strategy going into these rounds
um
yeah i was very focused uh against my i
mean against uh vichy i thought it's um
like very important actually to win
against him because uh he was the leader
at the time
and also i mean i didn't hadn't managed
actually to beat him in this game like
in my life so that was of course a very
good start
also winning against wesley was kind of
unexpected because
i'd lost two game against him before and
i managed to know to win with black um
yeah but there are always uh there are
always ups and downs um
yeah i
was very disappointed actually when i
rose to publiano because
i i just blundered in a very nice
position and almost risk-free
and also my loss against kurobov was
very heartbreaking actually because i
mean he's of course a very strong and
creative player
but
yeah but i
got to have a very good score against
him actually uh i think i won like five
plus games which play against each other
so um yeah that was heartbreaking but
then i managed actually to
to win i mean the last the last game was
kind of funny actually i mean probably a
branded even with 67 at some point uh
yeah it was very you know like nervous
game of course and
uh yeah but but it was fun of course and
um i'm very satisfied by playing overall
an incredible performance any final
words for your fans here in poland as
well as all over the world yeah i would
like to thank everyone who is
rooting for me
um yeah i said i'm very i'm very pleased
to win here in poland and uh
yeah i have had like a lot of support
here and there are many people so uh
thanks to to everybody and also to my
family and um friends and coaches and
everyone who
helped me achieving this success
ladies and gentlemen the champion of the
2022 superbad rapid m blitz yan shishtov
duda